this is a really important moment for
the RAF you have a new man in charge air
Chief Marshal Sir Richard Knighton and
he clearly wants to grip an issue that
has been incredibly demoralizing for a
lot of people in the Air Force and also
for those who are looking to apply to
join the Air Force concerns about
whether or not white men are being
discriminated against we reported last
year that the then head of recruitment a
woman called group Captain Lizzie nickel
had resigned in protest at what she
deemed to be an illegal order to
prioritize women and ethnic minority
recruits onto training courses at the
expense of white men she said that she
had she had received legal advice
advising her that this order that she
was receiving from her bosses was
illegal and despite that her chain of
command the more senior people right at
the top of the RAF all the way up to
then Chief air Chief Marshal sir Mike
wigston insists kept on insisting that
she implement this order she refused and
resigned her post that is what we
revealed last year in the wake of those
Revelations much more developed there
were allegations that under a previous
head of recruitment of the RAF the same
kind of practices had actually taken
place an inquiry was launched by air
Chief Marshall wigston to look into all
that it's culminated in this
72-page report that is being published
right now by the RAF I have to admit
they are being very open about this now
the new head of the Air Force has
apologized unreservedly to all those
impacted he said that he's also
apologized personally to group Captain
nickel who has lost her career over this
debacle Ben Wallace the defense
secretary was asked about this
um in the last hour or so and and this
is what he said but important to note he
was speaking before the put report was
actually published
while the whole thing has been I think
uh
a significant error and indeed a cause
for regret of the RAF they didn't lower
the standard they discriminated against
those people that were applying who were
above the standard so our military
output wasn't put at risk however the
treatment of the people applying was
what it was you know was wrong
unsatisfactory and you know I also think
that the treatment of the officer who
raised concerns and her very genuine
worries being ignored was something that
is needs to be looked at considerably
about why she was ignored why indeed she
was put under that pressure and I don't
want to see anyone put under pressure to
do something
like what we've seen in the RAF
it's complicated what happened the key
issue where this illegal discrimination
took place was in 2020 and 2021 when 161
ethnic minority and female recruits were
pushed onto training courses accelerated
onto these training courses at a time
when recruitment officers had different
legal advice that led them to believe
that this action was positive action
which is a legal way to try to improve
diversity no one's disputing that that
goal is a really important one for the
RAF the problem was though that at the
time people in the recruitment team were
raising concerns about the legality of
what they were being asked to do the
report talks about how whether or not
they were actually listened to or their
concerns he did and then when group
Captain nickel took over in 2021 she saw
all these practices that had been taking
place she according to this this report
she then went on to challenge her chain
of command when she was asked to
implement similar orders in 2022 now
that that order was never actually
implemented itself and but only because
she resigned and we even had uh air
Chief Marshall wigston when he appeared
before MPS last September still
insisting that there was no illegal
action taking place
I absolutely uh recognize the you know
the the reputational harm that was done
but as I've said that there was you know
some of what you said in your opening
remarks implied that there were
different standards applied that there
was active discrimination against uh
people who you know
white men
um but that was that was that was not
the case
and yet now we hear that it really was
the case it was the case during that
period in 2020 and 2021 it wasn't the
case in 2022 under group Captain nickel
but that's only because she refused the
order this is what the chair of the
defense select committee who was
quizzing air Chief Marshall wigston last
September this is what he had to say
when we caught up with him just now
I suspect that there will be a huge
appetite to call in uh sir Mike wigston
uh even though he's retired to answer
and question him on the results of this
report and what he said to us when he
tried to gloss over the seriousness of
what was happening when he last attended
back in February of this year
it's an uncomfortable moment for the RAF
the new leadership is clearly taking it
seriously and wants to draw a line under
it he said that the RAF will be taking
on and has already implemented uh a
number of the 12 recommendations for
improvements that have been made in the
report however he did say that nobody is
being held nobody is being blamed no
individual is being sanctioned and I
think that is going to sit quite
uncomfortably with all those who have
been impacted because what it means in
effect is that the one person who stood
up and called out what she believed
correctly to be illegal action in terms
of discriminating against white men had
to sacrifice her career while those
above her all the way up to the top with
air Chief Marshall wigston are not being
sang functioned in any way the head of
the RAF now says this is because it
really was down to a legal advice that
was incorrect at the time it was given
and that everybody at the time was
acting in what they believed to be a
legal way nobody was was trying to act
unlawfully that advice just changed and
that's why the circumstances have
changed I'm not sure that's going to sit
with everybody especially one final
thing because the Armed Forces Minister
said to me last year that should any
illegal or wrongful activity be found to
have taken place then those responsible
would be held to account